This variation of English rib produces
a wide, thick, textured fabric that
doesn't have a lot of stretch.
It has the racked texture on one side
and what appears to be one
by one ribbing on the other.
It's based on English rib.
Now, English rib is basically ribbing
in a one by one needle arrangement,
tucking every other row on one bed.
The tucking can be set up either
on the main bed or the ribber.
If you haven't worked English rib,
please watch this video at knititnow.
Com/englishrib.
It has tips and tricks for success
with this stitch pattern.
Once you're comfortable with English rib,
try adding some racking to produce
swung English rib.
It can be worked by tucking right or left
on either the main bed or the ribber.
No matter which variation you choose
to form this stitch pattern,
you'll be swinging the ribber
with the racking handle
and distorting the stitches.
Start by casting on for one-by-one ribbing
with the method of your choice
end with the carriage on your right and
the ribber set to P5 and knit a few rows.
Be sure you have the outside
needles on the main bed in work.
The needle arrangement
should start like this.
Now, before starting to knit,
let's take a look at our end needles.
We'll be racking to seven,
so looking closely, I can see that I need
to pull another needle into work
on the ribber to fill this gap.
Starting with the one-by-one needle set
up, racked to five, I'll set my main
bed to tuck in one direction.
For this brother machine,
I'm pushing in the right tuck button.
On a silver machine,
you'll set your cam to tuck
and your right side lever to tuck.
I'll knit to the left and both beds knit.
Knit to the right and the main bed
has loops over each of the needles.
But wait.
To keep our edges neat and to prevent dropped
stitches, we don't want
to tuck those end needles.
So every time the carriage will be
tucking, in this example,
when the carriage passes right,
I'll pull the end needles all the way out,
and they'll knit while
the rest of the needles tuck.
So the first sequence is rack to five,
knit left, all needles will knit,
pull the end needles out on that main bed,
knit right,
and all of the needles on the main bed
will tuck, except for those end needles.
The second sequence is rack
to seven and then knit left.
All needles will knit.
Pull the end needles out, knit right,
and all but the end needles will tuck.
Repeat sequence one and two
for the stitch pattern.
So knit a few inches and then stop.
Notice that my edges are neat and tidy
with no dropped stitches and these edges will
easily be seamed or they'll
stand neatly on their own.
You want to experiment a little bit?
Try tucking in the opposite direction
and continue knit for a few inches.
Sequence one, we'll tuck left
and knit right, and then rack.
Sequence two, again,
we'll tuck left and knit right.
When you drop the work from the machine,
by tucking on the main bed,
you'll see that the stitch pattern is
showing on the side away from you.
If you'd prefer to have the stitch pattern
showing on the side towards you,
set your ribber to tuck.
Do sequence one and sequence
two tucking on the ribber.
Be sure to pull those end needles out
and align that end those
end needles as you need to.